right let's let's give this a go here's
our water okay yeah yeah standard
polynomial i'm looking forward to vision
you know more or synthetic if you like
because you notice it's monic and it's
linear and then here because it just
says five the remainder I could go
through the whole division process and
then I will proper remain at the end but
it's a faster way is it there if all I'm
after is just the remainder I'm going to
use the remainder theorem if you can't
remember that we'll get to in a second
all right so let's do Part A let's do
this division I am gonna do it to that
it because it is nice and quick to do i
need my coefficients so i'm going to
write down to negative 1 3 & 1 and
what's this number that i route from
institute right that corresponds to this
number in here if i had asked you to
divide by X plus 2 what number would
have gone out the phone figured it would
be digging to exactly it's always flip
the room okay and by the way that lets
to be around 20 round is why as we go
through synthetic you add instead of
subtracting you notice in long division
you subtract on my own subtract the
lines in fact quite low because return
this backwards that makes all the
subtractions additions so now we're
ready to go what's the first step what I
do that first number than or two though
I just right now okay and then here
comes that repeated step the part that
gets us all of the resultant
coefficients so i'm going to multiply
and add which gives you
i'm gonna multiply and I which gives you
nine last one 18 and 19 okay so now i
have a bunch of numbers how do i
interpret this what does it actually
mean I'm gonna have a I'm gonna have a
new polynomial w and remained are right
think what's the degree that's the
degree of this polynomial we started
with look at the powers the degree is 3
that's the biggest power I can fit in
there right degree 3 and the degree of
what I'm / that's a GX the part 1 right
so when you divide degree 3 by degree 1
you end up with degree 22 you use your
index laws right so good morning so here
his first coefficient must be an x
squared that's that degree though Martin
this is a 2x squared then you've got
your 3x no I know what's that number on
the end there's no major okay so there
you go there's the division now puppy I
have left myself precariously a little
space but that doesn't matter because
good need much space to do this this is
part a for Part B the remainder theorem
is you might notice on this number at
the end right if I had just put in our x
equals 2 into here you would have gotten
let's let's just quickly crunching sorry
you would have gotten 2 times 8 minus 2
squared which is 4 plus 3 times 2 which
is six plus one okay so you're getting
16 take away 4 which is 12 plus 7 which
is 19 that's the remainder I ended up
with right so in order to further made
it directly all you need to do is
substitute in the opposite of this
number just just like we did here but
the opposite is not as the kid so
therefore i'm going to substitute ear p
of what will be the opposite of no
matter if we take you three very good so
I'll pop that in and this is just going
to straight out give me the remainder
okay I'm going to do one line to
indicate my substitution and then pretty
much from there I'm gonna reach my
calculator okay you don't need to do
this stuff in your head
I did my ex I was very easy and I don't
have a calculator my head but you have a
calculator there so if you haven't
already get it out and let's quickly
write down the line so substituting it
that's two times what is negative 3
cubed be careful she's negative right
you get a 3 minus signs in 13 months I'd
soon be negative 27 right good negative
3 squared is going to be nice so my
district 9 3 times negative 3 is minus 9
+ + 1 there you go now to toe I mean
okay like I said we could do this part
with calculators my name is 54 minus 18
plus 1 is someone ready got it someone
got the number
away cuz I are going tech later jessie
gets my 271 okay yeah happy times they
go remainder no division necessary
that's the whole point of using results
like the remit to do okay